Martin had not been very well for a
little quite a spell now you know and
but it's very very sad Martin was one of
those guys he had such a bright brain
such a intelligent footballer a great
all-round footballer a great guy as well
real gentleman very quiet very very
quiet fella but just one of the you know
true legends of the game that 1966 World
Cup winning team would be you know it's
a special team that will never be
forgotten and Martin was obviously a
major member of that team having scored
one of the goals jeffers going three
goals bobbing walk captaining the team
there was a massive West Ham influence
on the team along with the other great
group of players that were in that team
so yeah it would to be a player at West
Ham and growing up with Martino it was
15 when I went there Martin was 19 and
you know he was just a special player
could play anywhere midfield could play
fullback could play sent Ralph in
training he would even go in goal and he
was an incredible goalkeeper he just had
this amazing all-round talent yeah talk
to me about his footballing skills and
what made him so good have been looking
at a lot of the tributes that have been
flooding in over the last and a few
hours or so and the vast majority are
saying that he had very few if any
weaknesses us all in his game it was a
completely round player he could do
everything he you know he is a goal
scorer from midfield it arrived in the
box he had this incredible time and over
when to arrive when the ball was on it
you know he made these runs and just
arrived at a rasp lit second where
defenders couldn't pick him up and he
was a great finisher good in the air
could tackle pass he was just a complete
footballer really in a very very
intelligent footballer Ron Greenwood the
manager at that time you know he he was
a great coach you're not thinking you
know there Martin certainly anything
that he put on in training Martin picked
up very quickly and put into his game
yeah my producers just telling me that
he celebrated the World Cup victory with
a cup of tea with his wife I mean he is
now the fifth member from England's
greatest football team to be lost to us
it's another reminder that he can take
their achievement for granted
no I mean what they achieved was was
incredible you know I'll never forget
that day and watching a TV back at my
mom and dad's house you know and the
whole country celebrated that night it
was great and I think they got a
thousand pound of a man for winning the
World Cup it was you know the money was
was secondary it was the achievement was
was unbelievable and to be a part of
that team it's something that no one
could ever take away from him I'm sure
you know know my condolences to Caffrey
and his firm his wife and the family